herzlich willkommen bei Bild live an
diesem Donnerstagmorgen die Welt spricht
über dieses Foto und Bild hat die ganze
Wahrheit dazu ein Foto des Grauens das
um die Welt geht eine Sammlung von
Goldzähnen eine ganze Kiste voll damit
in einem ukrainischen Dorf das
monatelang von russischen Soldaten
besetzt war die Zähne von getöteten
Folteropfern der nächste Beweis für die
Kriegsverbrechen die die russische Armee
dort begeht ein neues Butcher ein Mini
Auschwitz wie das ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerium über dieses
Foto schreibt das hier das ist die wahre
Geschichte hinter diesem Goldzähne Foto
recherchiert von unserem BILD-Reporter
poweranz
ein Foto das die Welt schockiert an
dunkelste Stunde europäischen Geschichte
erinnert eine Kiste voller Zahnkronen
daneben eine Gasmaske doch jetzt stellt
sich heraus es scheint alles ganz anders
zu sein Bild viel zu Paul ronzeimer
begibt sich auf die Spuren der Kiste und
besucht das kürzlich befreite Dorf
pischkira kiewski dort trifft Paul auf
Sergej den Zahnarzt des Dorfes und der
erkennt die Kronen sofort wieder
das hier sieht den Szenen aus meiner
Sammlung sehr ähnlich ich habe als
Zahnarzt im Büro Weyer gearbeitet und
dort hatte ich einen Schrank der von den
Russen geplündert wurde
stammen diese Zähne von toten Menschen
oh mein Gott nein die stammen von
Menschen die ich in den letzten Jahren
behandelt habe ich habe diese Zähne
herausgenommen weil sich schlecht waren
und die Leute sind nicht gebrauchen
konnten in 30 Jahren habe ich 10.000 von
Zielen entfernt dies ist nur ein
Bruchteil davon manchmal nehme ich pro
Tag fünf bis acht Zähne heraus ich habe
meine Praxis seit 33 Jahren
der Mediziner vermutet die Russen
klauten die Zähne weil sie sie für
echtes Gold hielten
das ist kein Gold das sind schlechte
Zähne Reste von Prothesen wahrscheinlich
gehören sie zu meiner Sammlung jeder
Zahnarzt hat wohl eine ähnliche Sammlung
ein schlechter Zahn wird ganz gezogen
oder in Stücke geschnitten ich glaube
ich bin der einzige Zahnarzt hier der
andere ist vor zwei Jahren gestorben
wenn dieses Bild hier aufgenommen wurde
müssen das Zähne aus meinem Schrank sein
die zahnkronenkiste von Peschiera kisky
trotz all der Folter und Verbrechen der
russischen Armee hat sich der
schreckliche Verdacht nicht erhärtet
dank der Recherche unseres
bild-reporters Paul Ronzheimer
und jetzt live guten Morgen Paul in die
Ukraine diese Goldzähne die stammen also
offenbar nicht von getöteten
Folteropfern jetzt kommt aus vielen
russischen Quellen sofort nach seht ihr
alles Lüge dort in der Ukraine die
ganzen Kriegsverbrechen was antwortest
du
dass mir das weh tut dass das Dinge sind
ähm die ich
wo ich sagen muss nein natürlich gibt es
diese Folter ich höre das jeden Tag in
diesem Dörfern in diesen Städten wenn
ich in diesen Region unterwegs bin ich
habe aus Botschafter berichtet aus all
diesen Orten und immer wieder berichtet
was russische Soldaten der
Zivilbevölkerung der ukrainischen
Zivilbevölkerung angetan haben aber in
dem Fall muss ich sagen war das ja ein
Tweet den die das ukrainische
Verteidigungsministerin Ministerium
nicht so hätte absetzen sollen ich
glaube die Verbrechen sind schlimm genug
man braucht keine wie soll man das
nennen Übertreibung
Überzeichnung man sollte
das sagen was ist und wir berichten was
ist
darauf wollte ich noch mal hinaus Paul
auch wenn es einigen der Ukraine in den
Momenten nicht ins Bild passt es ist
wichtig in diesem Moment es ist
wahnsinnig schwierig aber die Wahrheit
über diesen Krieg zu berichten
absolut kai und ich glaube dass mein
Team war Team Sergej und ich die dort
gestern unterwegs waren auch mit dieser
Reportage und mit diesem Bericht zeigen
dass wir ausschließlich an der Wahrheit
interessiert sind dass wir zeigen wollen
was dort passiert dass wir zeigen wollen
welche
grausamen Dinge russische Soldaten eben
dort der ukrainischen Zivilbevölkerung
ukrainischen Menschen antun das wird ja
auch in diesem Bericht deutlich denn
unabhängig davon dass das was die Zähne
angeht die Kronen angeht dort nicht
passiert ist ist gleichzeitig eine
unfassbare Folter gegeben hat eben wie
in vielen anderen Dörfern und Städten
wir haben dort Menschen getroffen die
zusammengeschlagen wurden die berichtet
haben dass sie dort in diesen Keller
verschleppt wurden wir haben Anwohner
getroffen die erzählt haben dass sie
diese Hilfeschreie gehört haben Menschen
die dort in pisky radiewski eben
gefoltert wurden
diesem Keller in diesem in diesem Ort
und das ist etwas was wir berichten
wollen was wir berichten müssen aber
natürlich müssen wir dabei bei der
Wahrheit bleiben und dabei haben wir
eben festgestellt dass diese
dieser Artikel oder dieser Tweet vom
ukrainischen Verteidigungsministerin
mindestens fehlgeleitet war die Wahrheit
hinter dieser Goldzähne Foto also
deswegen bist du vor Ort Paul sprichst
mit den Menschen jeden Tag um genau
diese Wahrheit uns zu berichten noch
schwieriger ist es auf der russischen
Seite an diese Wahrheit dran zu kommen
was passiert da gerade in diesem Land
und da geht im Moment ein Video durchs
Internet das russische Reservisten
zeigen soll wir sehen Sie hier das ist
in der Belgorod Region also ganz nah der
ukrainischen Grenze offenbar dort mit
dem Zug angekommen gerade ausgestiegen
das sind hunderte Reservisten Soldaten
die offenbar so erzählen sie dort selbst
in dem Video gerade erst eingezogen
worden vor nach einer Woche und die
erzählen dort in dem Video dass sie ihr
eigenes Bargeld ausgeben musste um
überhaupt essen zu haben die sprechen
davon dass sie leben müssen dort wie
Tiere und dass sie kaum richtige Waffen
bekämen hältst du das für echt Paul
ich halte dieses Video für echt weil es
dem entspricht was auch wir hören was in
Geheimdienst Kreise uns erzählen was
insgesamt berichtet wird nämlich dass
die russische Armee überhaupt nicht
vorbereitet ist auf diese tausenden
Hunderttausenden Reservisten auf diese
Mobilisierung die dann passiert ist das
ist ja etwas was Putin unbedingt
verhindern wollte dass sie logistisch
nicht darauf vorbereitet sind das ist
nicht genügend Waffen gibt aber vor
allem auch geil und das zeigt dieses
Video das ist nicht mal genügend Nahrung
genügend Kleidung genügend von allem
gibt damit wirklich hunderttausende aus
russischer Sicht eben hier an die Front
kommen können und das zeigt vor welchen
wahnsinnigen Problemen die russische
Armee steht dazu gehört auch das Bild
von einem russischen Schützenpanzer an
der Front auch das Video gerade im
Internet
hunderttausendfach geteilt das ist ein
Schützenpanzer der dort über das Feld
rollt eine russische Schützenpanzer
kommt gleich auf uns sozusagen in diesem
Moment zu und gibt dann einfach auf his
die weiße Fahne die Besatzung steigt aus
auch das Paul für Dich ein typisches
Bild im Moment in diesen Kriegstagen
ob es typisch ist Kai das ist schwer zu
bewerten allerdings ist eines klar das
hatten den logistischen Problemen zu tun
dass die russische Seite große große
Probleme hat dass sie auch was die Frage
des Einsatzes von Militärgerät große
Probleme haben allerdings ich bin etwas
skeptisch was sozusagen diese
ukrainische Euphorie angeht ja man
erobert
täglich
jede Woche neues Territorium oder
erobert Territorium zurück allerdings
glaube ich immer noch dass die Russen
theoretisch wenn sie weiterhin 100.000
hier reinbringen und weiteres
Militärgerät hier reinbringen immer noch
ein sehr sehr schwieriger Gegner sind
für die Ukraine und dass das alles sehr
sehr lange dauert wird danke an unser
Bildreporter pauronsheimer in die
Ukraine danke für deine Recherche die
Wahrheit auch hinter dem Goldzähne Foto
das so sehr um die Welt ging danke dir
Paul
[Musik]